Transcriber: Hiba Dama
المدقّق: Ataa Al Ayoubi
مساء الخير.
لست هنا اليوم
للحديث عن نفسي.
سأخبركم اليوم كيف
تبدؤون شركة ناشئة.
أو شركة ناشئة بأقل المعايير.
إنه لشرف عظيم لأي أحد
أن يكون واقفاً هنا اليوم.
كل واحدٍ منا يحلم أن يمتلك شركةً ناشئة،
لكن ليس من السهل أن تكون رائد أعمال.
يتطلب منك الموضوع مجهوداً كبيراً.
لكن إن نجحت سيكون العائد كبيراً جداً.
لا تصدق من يقول لك أن ..
أن الرحلة ذاتها هي النجاح.
الأهم هو الوصول للهدف
عندها ستجرب طعم النجاح.
وتذكر دائماً
أن الفشل في بداية الطريق
هو فقط نقطة في الطريق
حتى تصل وتنجح.
عندما كان عمري 14 سنة
سافرت وعَمِلت
جربت عدة أشياء. جربت كل الأعمال.
جربت أفكاراً نجحت وأفكاراً فشلت.
لم يكن هناك أي مشكلة.
في أول مرة سافرت فيها
ذهبت إلى شرم الشيخ.
كنت صغيراً في السن.
جربت أحد الأعمال إلى أن اكتسبت الخبرة
وبعدها عندما أصبح عمري 17 سنة.
سافرت إلى الإمارات.
بدأت بالعمل في المطاعم والفنادق
وأي عملٍ وجدت
لم يكن مخجلاً أن تمتهن أي عملٍ هناك.
و من هنا كان لدي حلم.
كنت أتمنى أن أصمم تطبيق
للأجهزة الذكية
يكون فهرساً لمطاعم العالم كلها.
كان الموضوع بدايةً صعباً بعض الشيء.
أقنعت نفسي بمحاولة لتأجيل الفكرة.
بدأت بجزءٍ صغير.
بدأت أول مشروع من صفحة على الإنستجرام.
ثم طورتها حتى أصبحت موقعاً الكترونياً.
ثم طورته حتى أصبح
تطبيق هاتف ذكي.
إلى أن أصبحت فكرتي من أهم
تطبيقات الهواتف الذكية في الإمارات.
لكن، كان حلمي أكبر من ذلك.
فكرت بالأمر مرةً أخرى
ثم قلت لا، يجب أن أحقق حلمي.
لكن كان التطبيق يعود علي بأرباحٍ جيدة.
ولذا بدأت أستثمر في أرباحي.
حسناُ، كيف ننشئ شركة ناشئة.
سألخص لكم الأمر في خمس أفكار.
أن تكون لديك فكرة متميزة،
و أن يكون لديك فريق عمل
تستطيع الاعتماد عليه،
و أن تكون لديك خطة عمل،
و أن يكون التوقيت صحيحاً
ويكون لديك مستثمرين.
كي أفهم أكتر درستُ 50 شركة ناجحة
و50 شركة فشلت.
أهم عامل بينهم -كان مفاجأة بالنسبة
لي- هو التوقيت.
يؤثر التوقيت على نجاح شركتك بنسبة 40%
والعامل الثاني كان فريق العمل.
يجب أن يكون لديك فريق عمل عنده الشغف
والحب للعمل، وليس همه المال فقط.
والعامل الثالث الذي فاجأني
هو أن الفكرة ليست أهم شيء في مشروعك.
أنت تستطيع أن تأخذ فكرة
موجودة مسبقاً في السوق.
وتطورها لتنجح أكتر
من الأفكار الموجودة في سوق العمل.
والعامل الرابع والخامس
هما نموذج العمل والاستثمار.
وتستطيع تحصيلهما في أي وقت
ليس شرطاً أن تبدأ بهم .
حسناً، هناك شركات كثيرة بدأت
في مصر في السنتين الأخيرتين.
تطورت الشركات الناشئة
في السنوات الخمس الأخيرة .
أُسست 562 شركة ناشئة في سنة 2021
وأُسست 850 شركة ناشئة في سنة 2022،
هل نجحوا جميعاً؟ من المؤكد أنه لن ينجح
الجميع ولن يحصلوا على استثمارات.
حصلت 124 شركة فقط على استثمارات
في سنة 2021،
وفي سنة 2022،
حصلت 160 شركة فقط على استثمارات
إذاً، كيف نحصل على استثمار؟
إن لم يكن لدي الدراية أو المعرفة
لأحصل على استثمار،
سألجأ إلى ما يدعى بحاضنة الأعمال الناشئة.
حاضنة الأعمال الناشئة هي عبارة عن
حاضنة تحتضن رواد الأعمال
وتعلمهم كيفية إدارة شركاتهم
و تعطيهم كل المصادر الازمة لتطوير
المشروع وإيصاله للمستثمر.
حسناً، لو كانت لديك فكرة وتريد
عرضها على مستثمرٍ ما، ماذا ستفعل؟
ستبحث عن شركات “الاستثمار المخاطر”
وتعطيهم أسهماً من الشركة
ومن أرباحك المستقبلية
ولكن إن لم يتوفر لديك لا هذا ولا ذاك؟
هل ستقف ساكناً؟ لا.
أنا أؤمن أنه لو كان لديك حلم
لن تتخلى عنه أبدا.
عندما سافرت إلى دبي، كان لدي حلم.
لم أتخل عنه أبداً.
طورت من نفسي حتى ابتكرت تطبيق هواتف ذكية
وأخذت منه كل الأرباح
واستثمرتها بتكوين فريق
أول المنضمين إلى فريقي
كان شاباً قد عمل على ثلاثة مشاريع
باءت جميعها بالفشل.
عندما تواصلت معه كان مستغرباً.
لكنني فكرت بأنه قد فشل ثلاث مرات
فمن المؤكد أنه سيفيدنا
في تفادي كل الأخطاء التي وقع بها.
والشيء الآخر هو الشغف الذي لديه
بدليل أنه فشل ثلاث مرات ولازال مستمراً.
ثانياً يجب أن تحب عملك يجب أن تحب فكرتك
ابق واثقاً بفكرتك.
من أهم أعمالنا في الشركة
هو التعاون مع شركاتٍ كبيرة.
وقد تعاونا مع شركة جوجل.
أرسلنا لهم 140 بريداً الكترونياً
حتى قاموا بالرد علينا.
كنت لحوحاً ومصراً على تحقيق حلمي.
ثالثاً، عندما تدخل سوق العمل
تصرف وكأنك أهم الموجودين.
لا مشكلة في هذا.
نحن طورنا نظامنا حتى أصبحت أكبر
الشركات تتابع التطورات لدينا.
أهم نقطة هي أن تختار
فريق عملٍ تثق به ويثق بك
و أن يكون معك أشخاصُ يطورون الفكرة معك
أنت لست وحيداً
هناك الكثير من الناس إلى جانبك
المهم أن تبدأ.
شكراً.